WREEB BRIAN POLITICO LAYING OUT
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION LESS
CAN BE MORE.
LESS THAN THREE MONTH IN JOE
BIDEN WHITE HOUSE SETTLED ON A
PRESS STRATEGY FIRST DA NO
SELF-HARM IS KAMALA HARRIS
AVOIDING POSSIBLE BACKLASH BY
DOING SOMETHING?
HERE TO REACT IS MEDIA OPINION
COLUMNIST FOR THE HILL JOE
CONCHA.
TRYING TO GRASP AT A REASON WHY
SHE SEEMS DISINTERESTED IN THE
ASSIGNMENT SHE WAS GIVEN FROM
THE PRESIDENT.
WHAT DAY COME UP WITH.
>> I SEE THAT KAMALA HARRIS,
BRIAN, IN THE LAST EIGHT MONTHS
REMEMBER EIGHT MONTH AGO SHE WAS
CHOSEN AS JOE BIDEN’S RUNNING
MATE.
SHE HAS NOT DONE ONE PRESS
CONFERENCE.
BEFORE YOU SAY VICE PRESIDENTS
TONIGHT DO PRESS CONFERENCES I’M
OLD ENOUGH TO REMEMBER 2020 WHEN
VICE PRESIDENT PENCE DID DOZENS
OF THEM AS THE LEADER OF THE
CORONAVIRUS TASK FORCE.
HE WAS OUT THERE TAKING
QUESTIONS FROM THE PRESS ON A
DAILY BASIS.
SO THERE GOES THAT EXCUSE.
LOOK, WHEN YOU HAVE A VICE
PRESIDENT THAT’S BEEN TAPPED TO
FIX THE PROBLEM THAT SHE HAS NO
INTEREST IN SOLVING, THAT’S AN
ISSUE.
WHEN SHE COMPARED ICE TO THE K
CAN K AS A SENATOR.
AS A CANDIDATE SHE WOULD HAVE TO
ANSWER THAT I WOULD THINK DURING
A PRESS CONFERENCE IF A DOOCY OR
FISHER ASKED THAT QUESTION.
SHE WOULD ALSO HAVE TO EXPLAIN
WHY SHE THINKS ILLEGAL BORDER
CROSSINGS WHICH WE ARE SEEING
NOW BY THE HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS
IS CONSIDERED LEGAL IN HER MIND
AND THAT’S AN ARGUMENT SHE MADE
AS A SENATOR AND A CANDIDATE.
SO, HERE WE HAVE A CHRONIC
COMPLAINER IT APPEARS AND NOT A
DOER BASED ON HER ACTIONS
BECAUSE, AGAIN, IF SHE HAD
ANSWERED QUESTIONS AROUND WHY
ARE FACILITIES FILLED AT 17
TIMES THE AMOUNT AT THE BORDER.
HEARING REPORTS OF ABUSE SEXUAL
ASSAULT.
DON’T KNOW THE POSITIVITY RATE
AND A LOT OF THESE FOLKS ARE
RELEASED INTO GENERAL
POPULATION.
THIS IS SUPPOSED TO BE HONEST
AND TRANSPARENT INSTEAD ACTING
LIKE PYONGYANG WHICH WOULD NEVER
BE ACCEPTED UNDER THE PREVIOUS
ADMINISTRATION.
BRIAN: SEEMS LIKE A COUPLE YEARS
AGO WHEN KAMALA HARRIS HAD GREAT
ROLLOUT.
THEN WHEN SHE WAS ASKED ABOUT
ISSUES LIKE HEALTHCARE AND
BORDER SECURITY.
SHE SAID ONE RIDICULOUS THING
AFTER ANOTHER.
SHE COULDN’T LAST A PRIMARY ILL
PREPARED AS IF SOMEBODY GAVE HER
A TEST AND SHE FORGOT TO STUDY.
NOTHINGS THAT CHANGED.
I LAUGH WHEN PEOPLE SAY SHE WAS
HANDED A HAND GRENADE.
NOT REALLY, DO YOU THINK MIKE
PENCE LOVED GETTING THE PANDEMIC
PORTFOLIO?
NO, BUT HE EMBRACED BECAUSE YOU
HAVE GOT TO DO BIG THINGS IF YOU
ARE THE SECOND MOST POWERFUL
PERSON IN THE COUNTRY.
BIDEN DEFENDS HARRIS THIS WAY
WHEN I SERVED AS V.P. I ASKED TO
BE THE LAST PERSON BEFORE A BIG
DECISIONS WERE MADE AND VP
PROVIDED THE SAME COUNSEL TO ME.
SHE IS THE LAST VOICE IN THE
ROOM AND NEVER FAILS TO SPEAK
THE TRUTH AS WE WORK TO BUILD
OUR NATION BACK BETTER.
THEN WHERE IS HER POLICY?
WE HEARD SOME POLICIES PUT INTO
PLACE WITH MEXICO, HONDURAS AND
GUATEMALA ABOUT HANDLING THE
ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION COMING FROM
THEIR COUNTRY KAMALA HARRIS
SHOULD HAVE BEEN HEADING THAT
UP.
>> YEAH, BRIAN, SHE IS THE LAST
ONE IN THE ROOM BECAUSE SHE IS
NOT AT THE BORDER.
SHE ISN’T VISITING A BORDER THAT
SHE WAS PUT IN CHARGE OF.
WHAT ARE WE TALKING ABOUT NOW.
THREE WEEKS AGO?
THEN WE HEAR AN EXCUSE A COUPLE
DAYS LATER FROM THE WHITE HOUSE
PRESS SECRETARY NO ACTUALLY THE
VICE PRESIDENT IS IN CHARGE OF
DIPLOMACY.
AGAIN, THAT MEANS GETTING OUT
AND SEEING THESE PEOPLE.
NOT DOING PHONE CALLS.
WHY HAVEN’T YOU TRAVELED TO
GUATEMALA OR NICARAGUA OR MEXICO
IN TERMS OF SOLVING THIS PROBLEM
AND HOW DO YOU SOLVE A PROBLEM
AT THE BORDER WHEN YOU CAN’T
GRASP IT BY TALKING TO BORDER
OFFICIALS, BY TALKING TO THESE
PEOPLE RUNNING THESE MIGRANT
FITTINGS IF YOU ARE NOT THERE
AND YOU DON’T SEE IT, YOU CAN’T
FIX IT.
SO, LOOK, THIS IS A TEAM BIDEN
STRATEGY THAT SEEMS TO BE
PLAYING NOT TO LOSE.
IT WAS RISK ADVERSE DURING THE
CAMPAIGN.
IT’S NOW THE RISK ADVERSE
PRESIDENCY.
THAT ONLY WORKS FOR SO LONG
BECAUSE AT SOME POINT YOU ARE
GOING TO BE JUDGED ON YOUR
ACTIONS AND TO THIS POINT THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION HAS BEEN
ABOUT A LOT OF WORDS AND
SPENDING A LOT OF MONEY BUT NOT
A LOT ABOUT ACTUAL ACTION WHEN
IT COMES TO FIXING CRISES LIKE
WE ARE SEEING AT THE BORDER.
BRIAN: POLITICO WRITES BARACK
OBAMA BETWEEN TWO FERNS LATE
NIGHT TELEVISION AND DID A LOT
MORE INTERVIEWS AND JOE BIDEN IS
WE ARE NOT DOING THAT A LOT OF
PEOPLE QUESTION WHETHER IT’S RON
KLAIN RUNNING THE COUNTRY OR IS
SUSAN RICE RUNNING THE COUNTRY
BECAUSE SHE IS HEAD OF DOMESTIC
POLICY IT.
DOESN’T LOOK LIKE ANY ONE OF
THEM ARE TAKING THE LEAD OR